advocates say the city of minneapolis is
helping to write a new chapter for the
black lives matter's movement
in the united states this after the city
council reached a 27 million dollar
settlement in a civil lawsuit with the
family of george floyd friday
following his death in police custody it
comes just weeks before the first
officer charged in the cases
set to stand trial jeff begase has more
this was the moment last may derrick
chauvin with his knee pressed into
george floyd's neck for approximately
nine minutes it sparked a social justice
movement that led to a summer of unrest
and murder charges against chauvin and
now
a unanimous vote in the minneapolis city
council there are 13 eyes
a 27 million dollar settlement for
george floyd's family
on behalf of the entire city council
offer my deepest condolences to the
family of george floyd
the settlement includes 500 000 for the
community at the intersection where
floyd was killed
floyd family attorney ben crump it sends
a message
that the unjust taking of black life
will no longer be written off as trivial
the 27 million dollar amount is one of
the largest known police wrongful death
settlements on record
last year in louisville brianna taylor's
family received just over 12 million
dollars after her death in a botched
raid
the floyd settlement was announced on
the fourth day of jury selection in
chauvin's trial
so far five men and two women have been
seated
if a juror should hear that there is a
27
million dollar settlement with the
family the jury
has to believe that the city would never
pay that kind of money
unless derek tobin were guilty opening
statements in chauvin's trial are said
to begin
at the end of the month for cbs this
morning saturday i'm jeff begues in
washington